hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar manipulating trips and
digestion conditions to accelerate
digestion and improve signal intensity
for building a protein-based mass
spectrometric a say I am the Lexus
Krause of labyrinth and I'll be
moderating this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by leopards the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Agilent
Agilent is a leader in life sciences
diagnostics and applied chemical markets
Agilent provides laboratories worldwide
with instruments services consumables
applications and expertise enabling
customers gain the insights they seek
Adler's expertise and trusted
collaboration will provide you with the
highest level of confidence and their
clinical research solutions to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left ear screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the side window
click on arrows at the top right hand
corner of the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problems by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left to your screen
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Emma Zane
dr. Emma Zane is currently the clinical
chemistry fellow at Cleveland Clinic
clinic to learn more about our speakers
please click on the speaker tab found at
the top right of your screen dr. Zang
you may now begin your presentation
thank you for the introductions so today
my talk is on how to build a protein
based in mass spectrometry as a poor
clinical lab with specific focus on the
approaches that one can take are
manipulating chips in digestion
conditions for the development of rapid
and a multiplex protein assay so our
first reveal some of the common
limitations associated with amino acids
and then the reason why we're moving to
a mass spectrometry and then I will talk
about the differences between the top
down which is the bottom up Isis I will
also review the criteria for for
selecting stick inter peptide and
explain the different types of data
train profiles and finally the overall
process or pipette selection for
building or sensitive and a rapidly
protein based assay so model data are
presented here are form the first paper
little e here which is the work I did
with dr. Mario DeMarco at the sample
South Philly Vancouver Canada
you
also has been used for many years in the
clinical labs amino acids are not
perfect
for example interferences from auto
antibodies which has been published or
describing in many papers which can
cause falsely low results in a sandwich
essay and a falsity high result in a
competitive essay so just taking a
thorough governor as one example Auto
antibody is very common about a more
than ten percent of people are having
positive on the interior Goblin
antibodies and secondly anterior agent
antibodies which including the specific
antibodies and anti-animal antibodies
our hookah effects which is the only R
which is only applicable to a sandwich
email or asses so as a concentration of
analyzed increases above a certain point
the system calls are saturated and the
signal begins to decline and also the
lack of specificity are putting a
performance of fragments or PDMS cannot
be distinguished on the amino acid so
people have a paper published on the PTM
using our amino acids using mass
spectrometry acids that can detect
different isoforms of a PTH as and
lastly the matrix effect conversion of
existing are a tree of one amino acids
have found significant differences in
the accuracy because the interfering of
a tree are inventing ferjeen
so the
protein-based sa is analysis of the
intact protein so therefore no protein
digestion is required it is same so very
good approach but top-down method essays
is not a very common practice of world
clinical lab because there's only a few
labs now has high resolution mass
spectrometers and has a knowledge
working with integral protein analysis
so here I'm showing a example of a
top-down LC which were developing at the
Cleveland Clinic
for the identification of hemoglobin
variants so the sample prep is very
simple po blood was diluted and analyzed
for the LC mass back so for adults
you're going to see the very abundant
Alpha and the beta subunits a different
charged disc and aftermath deconvolution
the mass of both alpha and a beta
subunit is going to show up and if the
patient has a mutation for example
hemoglobin sickle-cell you're going to
see a shift of the beta mask from the
normal to the to the minus 30 daughter
if the patient is hemoglobin AAS you're
going to see both the normal beta
subunit and also the Shiva the beta
subunits
you
so the bottle up si which is a different
and then the top down which would recur
protein digestion those analysis is
based on the signature peptides which
represent the protein of your interest
and moreover the analyzer can be
multiplexed in one sense a so you can
measure more than one analyzed in a
method one mass spec assay
so the typical mass spectrometry used
either triple quadrupole mass
spectrometer running on the target hit M
our mode so e for people that don't know
well of M R M so in mr m the peptides
with specific mass is first the lactaid
of the first quadrupole fragmented in
the second second quarter Pole and the
reflected in the third quadrupole so
what we are talking about the one
transition is once precursor to a
fragmentary Empire
- SMS back play sporting ass is getting
popular for clinical applications
clinical labs are facing developmental
challenges and we'll multiplexing of
your targets there's even more
considerations so the answer has to be
using a single workflow that is suitable
for all targets a rapid walk of flow
mainly a reasonable asset turnaround
time a simple workflow and also the
research time and a cost
so these are the general considerations
some specific considerations would be
how to select your peptides and then
which part are used for quantification
are you using only one peptide or using
multiple peptides ion ratios which one
is your quantifier which one's your
qualifier and then matrix calibration
matrix and collaborators internal
standards are you using the SOP label
the whole protein or the peptide or the
the new word window peptides and in all
of this very importantly how to do the
sample preparation including the protein
digestion step
in a typical bottle up RS a workflow
sample has to go through several steps
before entering to the mass spectrometer
lipoprotein enrichment it can be immuno
precipitation immuno depletion to remove
those abundant proteins in your plasma
or serum or as PE
and then protein digestion peptide
enrichment like this is Kappa L C or the
FCX to fractionate your sample and then
sometimes there is a simple cleanup step
and I eat all of this the protein
digestion is the rate-limiting step it
can include the attenuation reduction
alkylation and as a medic cleavage and
the whole deduction process can take
hours to even a day which is make it
very impractical for many clinical
scenarios so here in this table
summarize a couple of examples of the
published or existing clinical acids
protein deduction time so April a was
and April be around 20 overs and the
second example is from dr. who finagles
lab of Seattle which is included a
multiple addition of trypsin the RP
address1 both overnight and then in
infliximab
assay for Mayo Clinic is also very long
recurs eating over digestion so if you
are in a lab which doing a high-volume
testing too long after that at some time
is going to lower your soup food and
also causing problem is how to schedule
your tack and discussion with stuff
you
another big issue is a sample deduction
willing to introduce the variabilities
variation of the data to perform at
different labs is the major contributor
to the overall variability of the essay
and people have also observed that this
coordinate measurement of the peptide
from the same protein used for the
quantification so for example the figure
on the right you're going to see to
those other peptides are from the same
protein you see a very nice correlation
but sometimes if you switch to another
peptide so correlation getting all very
bad the point introduction is a critical
step to the essay performance as the
completeness the rate at a stability
factor as the quality and also the as a
turnaround time so tools will help us
better understand the key factors in the
design of a sensitive and a rapid
Emmitsburg LC we evaluate here are
several variables that could affect the
rate of peptide cleavage the doulton
profiles and also signal intensities are
including the drastic crash or current
potential the DP relation energy CED
naturing conditions digestion buffer and
also trypsin great
this other five protein marker that we
use the index study so they are CRP RP p
4 0 9 t TR and april a 1
the first
of any peptide selection is basically or
bioinformatic routers there are also
some web-based tool that can help you
with the prediction so in this table are
summarized some of the selection
criteria which I used taking
consideration of whether it can be
detected basis facility like uniqueness
presented in Oso forms do not count in
any north NAB's or mutation no miss
cleavage I also try to avoid peptide
with PDMS or any other modifications and
moreover chemically stable and it can be
easily synthesized as internal standard
for quantification
so for those five protein markers we
have about the two to nine peptides up
our selection criteria and this table is
example of the MMO parameters we have
when precursor ions were for each
peptide and the three transitions were
monitored
you
the OTP series were optimized and by
doing so we actually observed an average
single increase of over 30 percent so
some other groups have reported similar
findings that a synchronous intensity
was much more important it's much more
improved when transitions are optimized
experimentally than using those
prediction equations
and to accelerate the doesn't process we
we used a very simple protocol in a lab
so technically - of a plasma serving
sample was mixed with the sample buffer
at one 250 Wallen ratio and the reason
we are using 10 microliters is for
either pep adding one microliter of a
sample is more than enough for the
detection of the 5 protein markers in
the study and then the nature at 1990
receive 40 minutes cool down for 5
minutes and then adding trypsin and
incubate and at the end we stop a
reaction by a satisfying and inject the
sample debug it to a carbon 18 column
coupled to a mass spec
so with using this protocol we measure 5
defense the buffers so they are
including a ambach Tris buffer of PDS
tips and ammonia acetate
we also tested three different ships in
grid because in grid trypsin which is
commonly used in proteomics PPC
Egyptians which is the pancreatic tips
with camel trypsin inhibitor typically
added and also bhavan pancreatic
Egyptians
we also compared with the proteomics
protocol that including using our SDC
salt I am big reduction alkylation and a
sequencing grade trypsin for deduction
and each of this of the buffer system
combination was digestive for half an
hour and also 18 hours and finally we
have about a 5 to 10 micro gram of
protein samples in jacket to the math
bag
so there is a lot of data being
collected from this a buffer trypsin
experiment and a which can be wheeled at
either the peptide the protein of the
protein panel level so here I'm just
using a plasma CRP pepper one as an
example so in this figure here the red
dots at the peptide peak area at a half
an hour digestion and the blue bar of
the full change in terms of the peak
area from half an hour to 18 hours at
the best buffered trypsin combination
are the ones that can produce abundant
signal and a half and over and a small
fold change about one from half and over
to 18 over so that means the reaction is
fast it is stable and is also non
decaying
so for example in this figure in the PBS
sequencing great case the peptides
produced at a half an hour are very low
but there's a bit increase of Omaha fan
over to 18 over so this is a slow
reaction
you
so in general the buffer studied here
are show the considerable differences
however variations as a result of chips
in grid selection was far greater than a
buffer systems
suburban trypsin are produced abundant
in signal at a half an hour but for the
general radiator a full change below one
Emil's of the buffer tested so that
indicate a loose of peptide a single
bomb half an hour to 18 hour digestion
and this is phenomenal is most likely
due to the cleavage by camel trypsin
known to be a contaminant in the trypsin
are purified from pancreatic stores the
genetically modified a sequence in great
trypsin has a slow rate of reproduction
earlier but a big signal increase of
from half an hour to 18 hours and a
lastly the tpc key trypsin produces a
medium intensity at an earlier time
point and the reaction is very stable
and along the key to give it all the
bubble results we found that typically
trypsin is favored and it is a producer
to rapid and a stable signal and also is
the cost-effective if you compare the
price between the TP secure chips with
the sequencing grid you are finding that
the chip-seq trypsin is actually a
thousandfold cheaper than a sequencing
grade
you
so we're searching for the best
performing the buffer trypsin
combination and only looking at a half
an hour and 18 overtime point there was
very little variation from peptide
peptide and within the same protein so
bastami of the alpha pepper form CRP
together we found that ambach pilate bck
trypsin is a best combination
however for the 514 marker we tested
there is a significant difference from
protein to protein and a bit in platinum
and a serum so was a better combination
405 in plasma we found that almost all
of the buffer chips and combinations are
favored resulting in your relative a
high signal at a half and over and a
fold change close to one as indicated by
the green arrows here
but in serums the trace buffer plus TP
security piston is a preferred
combination
so with the consideration for the sa
turn long time we also did a time course
experiment and I'm all interested at the
doulton profiles from five minutes to
his earlier deductions to 24 hours so
this test was done by using the buffer
trypsin system directly from the
previous experiments so peptides can
have a very different that doesn't prove
ourselves and it is to play very
different patterns they can be a slow
forming fast forming decay of sometimes
having this unusual profiles with
thinking of going up and down and up and
down again and the peptides which is a
fossil for me is the one that we're
looking for which is the best for the
development of a rapid sa so just
showing some examples of the profile so
here Y is the percent change in peak
area and F is that deduction time so in
general we observed a rapid release of
peptides when using the GPC k trypsin as
a compared to the sequencing grade and
in this plasma Co 9 + M big buffer all
of the five peptides of say on IR slow
forming we're using the sequencer green
trypsin but the reaction reached through
the reactions which is a maximum at a
very late time point around 18 hours
however when switching to the TP CK
trypsin Direction become much more
faster for example the figure on the
right the p1 peptide plateaued at 5
minutes and the signal is very stable
for the time course we examined it
and also Pap test from the same protein
can have a very diverse profiles so this
is sending is consistent with the poor
correlation of the mathematical results
in multiple peptides from the same
protein were useful quantification
and I using plasma TTR as another
example TP secret trypsin demonstrated a
faster release of all five peptides
compared to the 16 grid with a
comparable maximum signal intensity if
if change the web access to the pit area
instead of percentage area change
you
in a wind switch to the PBS buffer we
found that different buffer system can
affect the Dutton profiles and a peptide
can may perform very differently
in this assay online case comparing the
TP secret trips in PBS and a big buffer
the p2 is faster for me in PBS but is
agent in am big whereas the faster for
me peptide or p1 in the antic buffer
showed a very durable cells with signal
going up and down and up and down again
and we not obviously fossils really
superb tires in this case the RP in TBS
buffer no peptides are fast for me
and how about the in the sermon
phosphate buffer so are ppfor is a very
small protein with disulfide bonds
and many are PTMs though only two
peptides are considered for analysis
P one is of low forming is signals
increases to 18 over and ap2 peaks at
the 20 minutes stable to 2 over and then
start to decay and a sorcerer April a 1
we found two peptides are fast for me p1
and a p9 so all of the data above
basically showed that by selecting the
best-performing peptide the overall
putting that in the time can be can be
shortened like if your reaction finished
in 20 minutes or even 5 minutes why
doing overnight digestion
and we also observed no signal increases
with excess amount of Egyptian was used
in the system and we found that the TP
CK trip in stock is very stable it can
be stored up to six months at the most
20 degrees C
so the next question is heating a
creation time can it be shortened as
well so here we test a street
denaturation time at zero minutes means
note in iteration five minutes and ten
minutes and all exam the the profile of
digestion
so taken for example CRP and no heated
initiation
there's not many peptides are formed
before run over but if you look at the
profiles of the five minutes compared to
the ten minutes they are very similar
so five minutes is probably enough to
adjust the RP
the
so in April a 1 something is very
interesting we observe that there's two
pap tires
p4 and the p9r fossil forming
independent of hey denaturation so if
you are going to use p4 or the p9 into
your analysis the heat initiation step
can be eliminated
and as finally we are able to multiplex
the cypher markers into one essay so by
selecting the best-performing peptide
from each of the five protein markers
and we are combined into a 12 minutes LC
gradients we achieved a 20 minute
digestion by using a single workflow and
in addition there's only less than one
microliter of plasma sample is required
so very minimal of sample volumes so
using less sample is a big advantage for
massive head trauma tree assets compared
with those amino acids and it is a kind
of important for a pediatric setting or
for people doing a research when there
is a not many sample is available for
analysis consider a preterm baby in the
hospital in the ICU
how much blood he or she can provide and
also for people that are doing research
using animal models for example most how
much of the blood that the most control
light and how much of the blood that
people have in a bio bank
so just a little summary of the study
the DPC optimization is important which
we we all yielded a greater City percent
gain in signal the buffered trypsin
selection is critical it in generation
is also critical but it's only for
certain proteins as but not all and big
buffer plus TP ck chips and produce am
all produced a more abundant and
synchronous and a stable profiles
so by using two approaches described
here we we have developed and validated
a a plasma April a 1 SC and by using a 1
fascist performing a faster forming
peptide we achieve the 20 minutes that
just in time and the measurement showed
a very good correlation with new
phenomena tree the SA has a lower limit
of a quantification at a 0.01 gram per
liter
and some final words about this
presentation so the approaches described
here could be adopted to other protein
markers and a simple and rapid sample
preparation work flow will increase the
visibility of employment implementation
of a protein based mass spectrometry LC
in the clinical lab and we in the lab
dr. D Marcos at a sample Hospital we
actually use the same strategies applied
to our development of surrogate and mass
spectrometry LC at the end I would like
to thank a couple people at the
Cleveland Clinic dr. Wong dr. granik's
and dr. McShane and and also dr. Moretti
Marco Ramos and pulse after even cool
Canada who supervised me on the works
presented here
Thank You dr. Zhang for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
and I'll answer as many questions as
time permits so the first question is
no peptides past the mrm selection
criteria after trypsin digestion what is
the next step to take
um to trypsin is a pretty common for
proteomics and but beside trypsin there
are many other proteases you can't use
there's online - called peptide cutter
which you can paste your protein faster
fail the protein amino acid sequence and
then select the different ends and types
and is going to show you the resulting
or peptide sequence so trypsin is not
the only protease there's definitely
more on the market you can buy and you
can purchase and it use for your study
now is the tpc k trypsin commercially
available oh yes
t basic youtube c is commercially
available but the one thing i do keep in
mind is that not like the sequencing
grade it cannot prevent self 18 so what
you need to do you need to make sure
that your there is no sequence
similarity between the trypsin and your
peptide targets
now M our next question is measuring two
or more peptides from the same protein
for quantification better than then
using just one peptide
I will say yes for this question if the
cost is not a problem for your lab
obviously if you're using more careful
quantification you can to need to
purchase more internal standards and the
heavy labelled is can be very expensive
but the GU thing about using more
peptides for quantification is that you
can check the correlation between the
results from your peptide one to the
pipette 2 and if the patient have four
for example or snap or mutation that he
doesn't know and then you're going to
see a pretty and that case you're going
to see a very poor correlation between
the two measurements so it's pretty good
way for to ensure your ecology and and
also for checking the patient's results
and it looks like we have time for one
more question is there any application
tool that is able to help with the
building and analyzing a mrm method yeah
there's one which I find is pretty good
and I'm actually using is called a
skyline it's developed by the McCall's
lab from Seattle so is open access that
you can just download from their website
so it can help you with multiple things
can help you with peptide selections
building your mrm it can also help you
with data analysis which is a I know
most of the mass spec vendor have their
own software but this one just can do
everything in one package so it's pretty
good I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration we would also like
to thank Adalind for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through August
of 2019 laboratory via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye